hey guys so we're having an early
birthday party here today it's a dance
party themed that's why I've got two
light-up shoes and some things are going
on here
I've got like camo pants I got the pink
my outfit that I had on earlier was way
worse sounds like a little too bad but
these shoes helps umbrellas meet amazing
cookies does it like anybody that boiled
Sam's insert you know it's gonna be
mayhem watham wow it's all you guys
have to take the cheddar gosh this is
insane
pockets not here it's so great yeah I'm
a good dancer this is Matty's DJ cage he
has an iPad he's that bb-8 he's got some
other little things he's got his mixtape
he loves it give you your slobbering on
me honey
yeah snobby you look handsome though
look at it look good yeah
now it's gonna be it's gonna be perfect
masala crew you can mix all the music
and not interrupt mom's Matty do you
like it going on here positive is that
things have I'm here the bottle of Dom
we will drink Don Otto
lots of cuts yes
that's trying to say that there's no
dairy and Krispy Kreme Doughnuts happy
birthday Justin
we're only gonna do one candle because
I'm I'm 22 this year we were getting
enough natural we've already universe
I'm sorry sorry what I won last year
yeah do the math one
I'm true wanted to do so being 22 is
really great guys I love it thank toe
absolute you you were just 22 that's
okay we're going to get numbers at the
cake store for the cane thank you very
much you shut that down no no please
Barnes handle and they put on the cake
happy birthday jazz girls like I don't
know into really and a woman who cut my
hair today her name is Jasmine it's the
craziest thing is having me that's my
entire life wild day okay well let's
just beat this
can you believe it so you know your net
is graduate college right oh yeah
it's okay yeah but you gotta do it
I don't think the record will play
anymore yeah it's gonna work
yank it out oh is that anymore I did it
Wow Wow they said happy wiki jasmine so
they don't think I should give you a
heads up and not like yeah like it's no
longer impressive just put a bunch of
pages yeah this is like here's
what's this it's literally all cardboard
you wait get this take a tiny a shoelace
that okay not that one okay hi heart now
looks like cardboard what about this
let's just try everything is edible
Alexandre been so terrible
yeah what is this that's it that's it
that's the last you saw me as edible
that might be a dare is it fondant that
might be a dairy those are the smallest
pieces I've ever seen everyone cup
whatever they want daddy's getting a
little ice cream Street she froze I had
a microwave accordin look at him he's so
pumped you with your ice cream
oh my god Matt feeding Matt ha ha ha ha
be sad good morning Maddie quite the
wild party last night I had a good time
so thanks all my friends are coming and
uh I'm just waking up it's like 11:00
p.m. I mean 11:00 a.m. obviously um not
well oh this place is a mess now hmm I
don't feel like cleaning I think I'll
just go back to bed or maybe I'll just
drink a coffee except to edit so I'm
trying to get some work done I wanted to
take Maddie's count on so what I'm doing
is because I can't see behind me and I
want to still stay working I have off to
the side here I've got a webcam watching
him right here
so I can see behind me it's kind of like
a little bigger view mirror but for the
dog it lasted you I said I was going to
draw one of you guys a picture on the
surface book so I need to actually
figure out whose photo I'm gonna draw ok
let's see what some comments are let's
see newest first
um draw ok all right um we'll just keep
going which serves that was something
you're buying went to much much to get
this is the surface book Pro which is
right here no it's not service book Pro
it's just the surface book
I can't wait to draw on it I'm really
excited I leave a guy Weston beginning
to end without fast world thank you draw
a parrot from my channel
Justine make me picture my dog draw
yourself come on oh my god photo by U of
Maddie
draw me a squirrel I don't know how to
draw a swirl looks like everybody wants
me to draw Maddie can you draw him at
the dog as a human and Matt the human as
a dog ok I love this this is overdoing
Dale Martin you got it bro ok here's my
picture this is Maddie but human Matt
was a red bolt a hat on I'm not sure I
sort of gave up I was trying to figure
out a way that I can export the process
of drawing this picture I know you can
do it on the iPad but I'm not sure how
to do it on window so if any of you guys
know an application that I can use like
a drawing app or I can export it like
you can on the iPad let me know because
I would like to people do that so I can
join you guys some pictures oh yeah
here's my picture
cute little Maddy even like screen
recording apps what do you guys use for
windows because I don't know I get stuff
to capture gameplay screen play so I
guess I could just use that but I feel
like there's probably a specific drawing
application that I can use so let me
know in the comments below I'll see you
guys later
thank you for all the birthday wishes we
wrote things not until next week but
that's ok we partied earlier I'll see
you guys in the next video bye looks so
cute you guys want me to draw you
another picture let me comment below and
let me know what you'd like me to draw
for you actually bye peace out what a
great idea
rollerskating with your dog
haha